[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think she wants
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome
I'd like to ask you to please take your
seats at this time in a few minutes the
Graduate School procession will enter
from the rear of the auditorium and
we'll be using both aisles if any
graduates are having difficulty finding
their seats please find an usher to
assist you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we'd like to ask that everybody please
take their seats the faculty procession
will begin shortly thank you
[Music]
esteemed faculty colleagues families
friends and students I welcome you to
the 318th
commencement of Yale University and to
the 158 anniversary of the date on which
Yale confers it its first and the
nation's first PhD degree
[Applause]
today we celebrate our students
accomplishments as scholars and
researchers and we award the degrees
earned by your dedication to the
advancement of human knowledge we're
extremely proud of what you have
achieved in your time at Yale and we
thank you for your contributions to your
field congratulations to all of you
as we begin our ceremony I want to first
recognize those graduate students and
faculty who receive prizes at
yesterday's convocation your programs
list the student academic prizes right
now I ask all student prize winners and
their advisors who are present to stand
so we can thank the advisors for their
guidance and congratulate the students
Prize winners
[Applause]
now in its 21st year the graduate mentor
Awards celebrate faculty members who
have been outstanding teachers and
advisers of graduate students the three
faculty members who receive this award
this year exemplify the many important
qualities to which all graduates
teachers should aspire I asked our
mentor Prize winners in attendance today
to stand so we can again recognize their
achievements I think we
[Applause]
professor long represents the three
faculty out of all the faculty who have
helped you navigate graduate school you
have also been supported by many others
on campus whose labor and loyalty
contribute to make Yale the
distinguished University it is here just
a few these are people beyond the
faculty who stand at the heart of Yale
and when I finished we can thank them
together the university's custodial and
maintenance staff make our campus look
beautiful and keep us in all in good
condition all year ha the hospitality
staff meet us at commencement and
throughout the year the clerical and
technical staff conduct our business
with acumen and dispatch where would we
be without our registrar's
the management and professional staff
direct and administer our departments
and schools and we should specifically
thank that the staff of the Graduate
School of Arts and Science who sustain
the institution within which Yale
graduate education thrives for all these
women and men of Yale I write let's
recognize them with applause from
everyone
[Applause]
we also need to acknowledge the superb
musical abilities of our organist mr.
Chase Loomer is he down there no one of
the many accomplished students at the
School of Music now I want to say just a
few words to you our students receiving
degrees today candidates for the ph.d
MPhil and master's degree
before we begin conferring your diplomas
I know for many of you getting to this
graduation day has not been easy but you
have prevailed you have taken advantage
of all the Graduate School offers as you
pursued your studies and scholarly
research during your time with us you
have learned the way of research and
scholarship is neither straight nor
always smooth a line of inquiry may take
you nowhere and months of work may bear
no fruit an experiment could go awry and
you find yourself back at square one you
don't need to be told that graduate
study takes inspiration for sure but
also hard work and especially
perseverance and determination learning
to continue in the face of challenges
characterizes the ability to do advanced
research and the fact that you sit here
today means you have learned that lesson
today
you leave Yale as thinkers explorers
creators teachers and as many of you
heard at our recent where do I go from
Yale day you also leave with a set of
skills that equip you for a variety of
careers your innovative and critical
thinkers problem solvers leaders team
players and effective communicators
poised to launch fulfilling careers
whatever direction you choose to apply
your skills of advanced learning let
your accomplishments here inspire you to
tackle new challenges with the
confidence that you have the skill to
navigate all difficulties as a Yale
graduate
you are given an opportunity to
contribute to society and to make a
difference in your field of study
as you go forth I hope that you will
also stay engaged and in touch with us
as alumni and considering mentoring
those who follow in your footsteps it
has been my privilege to lead the
graduate schools efforts to provide you
with the environment in which you grew
to the scholars you are today I'm proud
of what you've accomplished and excited
to see what you will do next
congratulations
so we will now award the graduate
degrees we will call the graduates to
the stage by department or program in
which they have earned their degrees for
those students receiving more than one
degree all diplomas will be awarded
together
Dean Pamela Sarah Meister will read the
citations please come forward as your
name is called to congratulate the
degree recipients we will be joined in
the front of the stage by faculty
members from each department or program
you are more than welcome to give
applause to individuals as they go
across the stage that we do not consider
that info I did all we welcome it
Dean Shaw Meister
for the PhD in african-american studies
Phoenix Alexander
[Music]
Lauren Meyer
[Music]
[Applause]
Danya em telegram
[Applause]
Claire Schwartz
and for the master's degree damar
francis lewis the fourth
[Applause]
for the master's degree in African
Studies Katherine love Iran lalla day
aloo Shambhala for the PhD in American
Studies Suzy on
[Applause]
Jorge Enrique clay uh Molly Anderson
green Pedro amore regalado Santos
[Applause]
ela Tyagi and for the master's degree
sing la madeleine han
[Applause]
Joseph Buchanan Landman
[Applause]
[Music]
Cooper Weissman for the PhD in
anthropology
Louisa courtesy tanam below Vasily
Ronaldo Russell oh and rainy Amelia
Elizabeth McMullen sansuyu for the PhD
in Applied Mathematics
Sahil our girl wall
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Nicholas Fox
Marshall
[Applause]
for the PhD in Applied Physics
Christopher James axe line
[Applause]
for the masters of science Elizabeth
Megan Bell for the Master of Arts in
archaeological studies Jordan bogan
[Applause]
Rachel Marie Rose Logan Alexandra
Elizabeth McKay
[Applause]
Kanak somani Patrick Clinton Wiley for
the PhD in architecture Eugene H Shawn
[Applause]
for the PhD in astronomy Maria Jose
Barrera Pinochet for the PhD in cell
biology Brittany Lynn and gorillas
Michael William groan Sara Elizabeth
Hill
[Applause]
yo harmoo
[Applause]
Jessica faith Johnston
[Applause]
mom ciao MA
Maria issues alert a Kyrgyz
[Applause]
nor toss ramen
[Music]
[Applause]
Levi Merlin Smith
[Applause]
Elizabeth when Sun
[Applause]
for the PhD in cellular and molecular
physiology Lindsey Catherine's tavola
[Applause]
for the PhD in chemistry Jacob William
black
[Applause]
and Monroe Carroll
[Music]
[Applause]
Janelle Kristen Castillo Laura
[Applause]
Carolyn Chandra sin
[Applause]
Alex James chin
[Applause]
Lila Shriram dota
[Applause]
Kenneth Albert young
[Applause]
Alexandra he tuned
[Applause]
Shane Healy
[Applause]
shush and MA
Adam John Mutulu
[Applause]
Alexander Paul Perot Beck
[Music]
[Applause]
christopher ryan she grew angeles stein
our Matthew Douglas Streeter Chad David
torjussen
[Applause]
Anita Turek
[Applause]
belong
[Applause]
deep til Mazumdar
for the PhD in classics
Rachel Lily love Cynthia
Carolyn polls Lee
Jennifer Lee Anne Cecilia wine trip
[Applause]
for the PhD in comparative literature
Julia
hazel powers
Noemi novel
[Applause]
for the PhD in computational biology and
bioinformatics mangu
[Applause]
Michael at Jack Klein
[Applause]
and for the Masters of Science near new
mark
[Applause]
for the PhD in computer science
Elena Carina grigora
[Applause]
John Kim
[Applause]
a DT Ramachandran and for the Masters of
Science Tao Chen hue Wang Chan
are you young
[Applause]
your thing
[Applause]
something
[Applause]
sahib singh groover
hyung goo
[Applause]
Chinchin he you know Joe
[Applause]
you're in Heinlein
her role a mealy sweetly
[Applause]
darling
[Applause]
John law
[Applause]
Jeanne law
[Applause]
yawning mouth
[Applause]
John moon
[Applause]
Oh jung-hee ow
[Applause]
OOP Ungh
by shoe air Shawn
shirty on way
young song
how
- reaiiy
[Applause]
jinx Anyang
[Applause]
on you
Ling song Zhang
[Applause]
jinghuan John
[Applause]
when Jia drone
[Applause]
Zi Han bro tongan Zhang
[Music]
joshan Jane
ding doh
[Applause]
true she child
[Applause]
for the PhD in East Asian languages and
literatures Maryellen friends booming Li
[Applause]
Samuel a sure Melissa Hmong Xiao Wang
[Applause]
for the Master of Arts in East Asian
Studies eating Chung
Eric Jose Coronel Esteban
[Applause]
Samuel Gonzalez
[Applause]
shouting low
[Applause]
marry Patricia Mulcahy
[Applause]
youngji show
[Applause]
shanon's song
[Applause]
Bowen wah
[Applause]
Jin Yong
[Applause]
John Jie Zhao
for the PhD in economics Antoine I'll
knew ghin oak doll
[Applause]
go Rocha plume car
[Applause]
Taha Shipman Fabian Paul Eckhart Wingo
[Applause]
URM Hubner
[Music]
[Applause]
you Joel one
[Applause]
Philip collect man
[Music]
[Applause]
dong-hyuk in
[Applause]
Tatyana Klinenberg
Louise laga
[Applause]
you can do
a djalu
[Applause]
max Perez Lyon Kino so Michael andreas
pump 'l Jin jack you messy Yuki Sawada
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Fabien Lawrence try Jaya even when
[Music]
[Applause]
linglong
[Applause]
a young one Giovanni
[Applause]
for the MPhil Daniel Alexander Novick
goldstein
Johannes Biederman
and in Engineering and Applied Sciences
for the PhD in biomedical engineering
draw Chen
Alexander James Engler
in Linz Meyer high n low
[Music]
Samuel keep you a go Mary teen Adele
s retarding
you know in Sioux
young Shaw
and for the master of science we Li Chen
[Applause]
Julia Angela Dugas Catarina Anna CELAC
[Applause]
jingo Kevin Joseph Lima
[Applause]
Jason Liang
Solomon Ruchi
Jing Tian Wang and for the PhD in
chemical and environmental engineering
John hi boo
jung-woo to Michael Joseph ginetto
Anna Louise Hagstrom
[Applause]
Patrick Hahn
[Applause]
Lindsay be macmillan brown Andrew
Jeffrey some nerd
[Applause]
and for the master of science
audrey grace warren john way
send you one
Jason Samuel Lipton
[Applause]
Thomas Edward Rimmer Julianne Naomi Rolf
making young
- holla line and for the PhD in
electrical engineering
Maroof I mean we are
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Zachary Alexander cobos chang-jung
and for the Masters of philosophy in
mechanical engineering and material
science Gillian Christine Cochran for
the PhD in English language and
literature
Andrews Stuart Brown
[Applause]
Margaret dream dilly sir he in
and Elizabeth Killian
[Applause]
Alexandra Vance Ryder
[Applause]
and for the Master of Arts Sarah hoop
Smith
[Applause]
William Alexander Worrell
[Applause]
for the Master of Arts in European and
Russian Studies
Arina Belova
[Applause]
Catherine Maura
- salir Sara
aleem Francis Holsworth David Levesque
Tina Rodriguez Nathan Williams fair
Emma Lucy Simmons
[Applause]
Daria smirnova Roxy son
Isabel Celeste than passion
[Applause]
for the PhD in experimental pathology
Nathan founds Britta
Helen hunka molar
hope by Wong
for the PhD in film studies Mallory
[Applause]
for the PhD in forestry and
environmental studies Jill Roberta Kelly
Lili Zheng
[Applause]
[Music]
for the PhD in French Jennifer Alice car
[Applause]
for the PhD in genetics Christian
Charles Dutton Harmon
[Applause]
Ronit Sharon Kaufman Edward Marsh
Parker Logan sakowski
Durga cockerel
each on John
for the PhD in geology and geophysics
Elizabeth grace Clark
[Music]
[Applause]
Devon Cole Robin Ruth Dawson
[Applause]
je dang
[Applause]
Caitlin Elise gray
[Applause]
snarl ooh on where mutant hold your
Peterman Azusa takishi it G drank
[Applause]
for the PhD in Germanic languages and
literatures Ola hints
[Music]
[Applause]
Regina
Hana Lucilla Karl
[Applause]
[Music]
susan-elizabeth morrow
[Applause]
for the PhD in history Charlotte Amalie
Abney Solomon honor Barzilai Flynn
Jamison Crotty John's web gram the third
Catherine Heather ray Healy Andrew
Michael Hogan Lauren Gottlieb elections
Kevin Lucas lord Timothy Wayne Lorick
[Applause]
Catherine moss
[Applause]
Zachary Adam Mazur Laurel joy wake hi
[Music]
[Applause]
ben staunton ovitch
why chard Chang
[Applause]
and for the Master of Arts Mary Adeline
a Wald
[Music]
for the PhD in the history of art
magdalene breidenthal Kirstie Sinclair
Doutzen
[Music]
[Applause]
Evan John Freeman
[Applause]
Sophie Rose Linford Alexandra Kathleen
Marcin
[Applause]
Christopher will keep lats
[Applause]
Samuel Sakharov Audrey sands Nicole
Jerry Williams Caitlin rose Woolsey for
[Applause]
[Music]
the PhD in EM you know biology yem
stretched Edessa
a collar
[Music]
[Applause]
Jan Jung Cho Ross Stephen Fetterman
[Music]
Phillip Kong
Vivienne Yu Jing Lim
jae-hoon Shen
[Music]
[Applause]
for the PhD in the interdepartmental
neuroscience program
Jonas Casimir ballina
[Applause]
Brian yep
dan jealous
[Applause]
Alexandra grew bzees Lydia Johanna
Hofstetter Stephanie Marie Noble Matthew
peva for the Master of Arts in
international and development economics
Raphael Mao Nanyang
[Applause]
Mitali banerjee ithi Bhargava
[Applause]
Gretchen Elizabeth Biermann Luis Eduardo
Castillo Aguirre Sofia Theresa cocido
[Applause]
John you fan show your cow Sakshi Hollen
[Applause]
Louie
sefa and jiang
[Applause]
masakazu Kamakura
[Applause]
John Hulu
[Applause]
Renee leave us
[Applause]
Li Chen lo
[Applause]
Brian McCann
[Applause]
prima sigh Narasimhan sullen as Dogon
[Applause]
Aishwarya Patil
[Applause]
Muhammad Hassan Saad Nerine core Santo
[Applause]
Ritu Parnas Sagnol
[Applause]
koke Sarah
[Applause]
partial pencil Shah
Nikita Sharma
[Applause]
your skirt 80eec
[Applause]
when went a
[Applause]
Supraja Avadh lomani you Jia Yong Yong
you
you zoo
for the PhD in investigative medicine
Christopher Han Jung Lee Dennis Ghulam
Hussain mullah Dina for the PhD in
Italian language and literature
Christopher Matthew Kaiser
[Applause]
Anna mara
[Applause]
Lucca Peretti
[Applause]
for the PhD in law
again for the PhD in law Alyssa
Elizabeth Stimson King
[Applause]
for the PhD in linguistics Sean M
Gleason Alysia and Nicole Harris
[Applause]
Ryan Maurice Cossack
[Applause]
Luke Steven Linderman for the PhD in
management
Aruna Gupta
[Applause]
weenie young Jiang Ming kyung kim
[Applause]
donna's leritz
[Applause]
then sang-hun Matthews
[Music]
[Applause]
Victoria Shu John
[Applause]
and for the Masters of philosophy Eric
Olson
[Applause]
for the PhD in mathematics Michael Paul
Landry Florencia a rose
[Applause]
lamb fam
[Applause]
for the PhD in microbiology
John D Ventura
[Applause]
for the Masters of Science the set
Suzanne Velasquez for the PhD in
molecular biophysics and biochemistry
Ruben atill Oh Kelly jokl Haines
[Applause]
Catherine Irene Farley Barnes Ethan
Michael Loudermilk
[Applause]
Carrie Thomas Lipton
[Applause]
Jimmy Craig Miller
[Applause]
Stephanie Rekha knee
Michael laughs Ruttenberg Schoenberg
[Music]
Sara Cirrus mugga
[Applause]
Taniya Christine Valerie
[Music]
Samantha josephine Ziggler for the PhD
in molecular cellular and developmental
biology
Brendan Lee Barco and Marie peek at en
Greenlee
[Applause]
Paul Michael Muir for the PhD in music
Andrew J Chun
[Applause]
Angharad
Jane Davis
[Music]
[Applause]
Joshua Dalton Gailey
[Applause]
mary-elizabeth horn
[Music]
[Applause]
John Francis clays
[Applause]
mark Alexandre Alessandro lad mark Alan
Rogers
[Music]
[Applause]
Peter Nelson Solinsky
[Applause]
for the PhD in Near Eastern languages
and civilizations Matthew D Glassman
[Applause]
Julia patient che for the Master of Arts
Nicole
Marielle a lot for the PhD in nursing
chingling ding
[Applause]
for the PhD in pharmacology Zachary
Ghanem
[Applause]
Leah MA
[Applause]
David Edward polio
[Applause]
for the PhD in philosophy Daniel Everett
Myrna
[Applause]
Allison paneros Glasscock
[Applause]
Juan Sebastian Pinero Sanchez for the
PhD in physics
Salvatore Iola
Andrew David Gus Barrow Elena Graham
aleni
[Music]
dun dun G
[Applause]
during JIAJIA long Makela
Paganini
Meredith Clark Powell Lucy - Rena Cova
[Applause]
find road rude
Rachel and Cooper for the Master of
Science for the PhD in political science
Consuelo I'm at Mateus Ian Charles
Crichton John Arthur dear Blanc
[Applause]
Nick are Gaikwad lisa rose Gilson Lynne
Marissa Hancock
William George Nomikos
[Music]
hurry Narayan Ramesh
[Music]
mara Redlich Rev can honor oxen ha
[Music]
[Applause]
andris Ricardo Vargas Castillo Elizabeth
AIIMS Wellman for the PhD in psychology
Ava
Teresa casados
[Applause]
[Music]
you know Chung
[Applause]
Molly kretchner Crossman
[Applause]
Gordon craft Todd
[Applause]
David Ellis melnikov
Aaron Nicholas Santosh coy
[Applause]
Michael Nicholas stag narrow William
Michael van der Linde
[Music]
[Applause]
for the PhD in public health Megan
Elizabeth Cahill Bonnie
gin
[Applause]
sin you only
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Margaret Elizabeth mayor olga Morozova
[Applause]
mashite no tile
[Applause]
yes mean Salinas
william Lewis Spiro tiara Capri Willie
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Lee Zhang
and for the master of science you a
child
Sammy hubba Sh
see on e
yah Xiao Jia
wooju Korea
[Applause]
see diem Lu
nicknamed you
who is a Nadeem Nerissa
[Applause]
you June pan
[Applause]
Melanie Rosenberg Arriba and Breen
Tarek she you Wang Xuan Yao
chin y'all in
Eric Jing
tianyu on John
when phone dong
Bianchi ciao
you Jia joke
[Applause]
for the PhD in religious studies Ryan
Michael dar
[Music]
Scott David Davis
Samuel Joseph long carve James Edward
naughty
[Music]
[Applause]
Zachary deferred Smith for the master of
philosophy
Cody Carolina Brown muscleman and for
the MPhil in Renaissance Studies Kelsey
Elizabeth champagne for the PhD in
Slavic Languages and literature's Daria
is a roba
[Applause]
Amanda Zoey Lerner Victoria Perrin yuck
[Applause]
Megan why race
[Music]
or even star young for the PhD in
sociology James Walter Abbott in Kwan
Chung jean-baptiste dominique louis
fernandel pal
[Applause]
Todd Michael Madigan
[Applause]
John - pin our Celine Raymer
Reynolds hero Casas Salado through the
Masters of philosophy Tina law and for
the Master of Arts Vanessa
Kristen Bittner and Elizabeth Taylor for
the PhD in Spanish and Portuguese Edwin
Stewart Atkins the second
[Applause]
Catherine Lynn Brown
and for the Master of Arts gustavo race
the silva Lauro for the PhD in
statistics and data science derek Feng
[Applause]
for the master of arts and statistics
Alexandre Giorno
[Applause]
June 1
minkyun can
[Applause]
David Koch
[Applause]
pratik Malik Jenkin chewy
shuhang law
yugioh wha
[Applause]
Alysia Michelle Williams you taro Yamada
[Applause]
Jingwei John
Ling Jiang Joe
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now I ask as I call out each degree
for the recipients of that degree to
stand and remain standing after which we
can congratulate all of them together
master of arts stand Master of Science
master of Advanced Study Master of
Philosophy Doctor of Philosophy
okay don't sit down stay right there
it's one of our traditions at this point
to recognize the commitment of time
effort and attention required to achieve
an advanced degree is only possible with
the participation and support not only
of your professors and classmates but
also your families and friends therefore
I invite you all of our degree
recipients to turn and acknowledge roles
placed played by others in the
achievement we are celebrating today
[Applause]
okay now you can sit down you have spent
time in one of Civilizations highest
inventions the research university where
the mission is the creation of new
knowledge as you've learned finding new
knowledge new truths about our world is
not a solitary endeavor you have lived
within an academic network in which you
can follow your curiosity rigorously
test your ideas have the critiques that
spark new ideas and go in unexpected
directions you have learned at a
convincing argument backed by evidence
from primary sources or well controlled
experiments will stand up to critiques
and importantly pave the way for the
next person to take another step savor
this rejoice in this it is a rare
privilege to live this experience I
would argue that it is now your
responsibility to spread that knowledge
beyond the university whatever your
future wherever your future takes you
share what you have learned and what you
will learn our world needs to know true
things
backed by hard-won evidence now more
than ever
be the source of truth in the midst of
confusion and misinformation and bring
all your wisdom to bear on that truth be
the mentor of young curious people who
are budding truth seekers take what you
have learned at Yale and make the world
a better place on behalf of all of us at
Yale congratulations
graduates families friends together with
the faculty and staff who are with us
are invited to a reception immediately
following the conclusion of this
ceremony at the Calkins courtyard at the
mcdougal Center all the students started
out there this morning please join us
for this celebratory occasion as the
public the School of Public Health will
be holding its graduation ceremony
immediately after hours please all
remain in your seats until the platform
party recesses from the auditorium
then please process out to the reception
under the guidance of our Usher's as
quickly as possible thank you
[Applause]
[Music]